foreign
[Music]
of the view from 22 and since the ashes
are ongoing and are in my opinion and
the opinion of many people I know the
most interesting thing that's happening
this summer uh we thought we'd do
another ashes special with the great
Henry blofeld Who's Back Again by
popular demand and is kindly agreed to
do
an appearance after each test we hope
we'll get hold you to that Henry uh and
we have some good news to report which
as everyone knows England won the last
test match heading it by three wickets
it was another thrilling test match and
it sets the series up very nicely uh
with the Australians even two to one
um Henry first of all I was with some
Australians on Sunday and uh they were
quite charitably saying they wanted it
to happen because they want the series
to be thrilling and nobody really wanted
three nilam for it all to be done and
dusted as it were
it's always worrying when the
Australians are charitable isn't it you
might have done something wrong yeah
no I mean I think that's absolutely
right but actually when you think of it
we've had three matches that have gone
down to the wire and I happen to believe
England the probably the better side and
then if they had got this right if they
hadn't been so uh
dedicated to basketball and rather a
blind way I think they would they they
should be to one up themselves if not
three nothing up uh but as it is they've
come to terms with uh what the
Australians have done which is teach us
um the fact that with basketball on his
own there's no solution to anything it's
got to be tempered with discretion we've
learned that and we won the a wonderful
Victory I thought it heading there as a
result of that and it's worth pointing
out straight away that the Innings that
saw us to Victory Harry Brook who made
75 played a proper Cricket Innings and
at this level uh proper Cricket innings
are the things that I think are most
probably most important in the long run
yes and you would say you would put it
down mostly to the change in attitude
and there's a bit more discipline not
the new selections who actually
performed very well
oh yeah suddenly they did I'm not
putting down old one thing but the fact
is that basketball they started off
probably hit that first ball for four
days and didn't hear first ball to be
out of this series and everyone thought
this was going to be a big bang wall but
now absolutely spended England scored
393 for seven or whatever it was on the
first day and they thought yep we're
away well it's not quite worked out like
that because Australia plays deep fields
from the start and to restrict the flow
of force and I thought dealt with it
very very well and intelligently and
they won both those first two test
matches in tight finishes uh but England
have modified their approach and I think
this means that they are playing better
more sensible and ultimately winning
cricket
let's discuss that really quickly
because I think I'm in the now minority
pros at Crawley Camp just because I love
watching him bat I think he's such a
beautiful batsman oh I'm I'm I'm not
against Crawley I think I'm not I'm not
against the fact he hit that first ball
voice it was a friendly moment I'll
never forget it but um and I'd always
have him in my side good Heavens yes I
think he's worth the risk and and he is
someone who is has been infected If You
Like It by basketball although or maybe
you can say that the fact of bazball has
helped him develop his natural game and
I'm all there because I'm going in first
and doing that I mean after all
throughout the history of cricket I can
think of several people who came in
Smith of the West India less traveled
south Australia who went in and gave it
a big bang at the start and I don't
think there's any harm in that at all no
no don't think I'm against Crawley I'm
not okay good good I'm glad we agree on
that
um the um I suppose one thing that the
bathroom that people point to is the
average his average is not great
um but then he does what bazball's meant
to do which is put pressure on the
opposition by being aggressive
well he does but then that averages
aren't everything are they uh I mean I
mean it it in terms of bowling it's a
question of who you'll get out you'll
get top bats now or do you in fact pick
up tail Enders all the time it's it's a
very important distinction that and I
mean and and going in first against
Australia uh and he did against anyone
Crawley will make his uh his shower or
other more than his share of those
scores perhaps but when he comes off it
it does do quite a lot to put the
opposition really onto the back foot and
staring them towards Victory yes and uh
the squad for uh the next test match at
Old Trafford has been announced uh folks
is not in I remember you saying on the
last episode uh that you would you think
folks probably should come in for
bairstow to free him up to keep him in
the side but to throw him up to bat
um doesn't look like that's happening oh
it's not happening uh no I think I
personally don't agree with that because
I think faster at the moment I don't
know that he broke that leg last we are
playing golf I'm not sure he's fully fit
um I don't know of course I don't but
the fact is that he's dropping endless
catches behind the stumps he's very
untidy behind uh and stumps and since
that's 78 in the first Innings of
edmiston he's not been getting runs I
personally would have paid folks in this
test match because it's crucial that we
win it and now for every Snick that's
got to be picked up every chance behind
the stumps every chance everywhere and I
think this is the one failing of this
England side so far and it's gone into a
basketball tour they are Butterfingers
their catching has been simply about
appalling I mean Joe wrote I mean he'd
been bad normally he's so reliable I
don't know what's happened to him and if
you're in in a tight situation like this
catches are terribly important and we've
got to hang on to every chance we get
folks I think would have given us a
better chance of doing that yes do you
think it might be that was it not that
Stokes that actually broke his uh leg
and and therefore is is indebted to keep
picking him uh because he was
responsible for the injury
yeah
is it I I hope it does that isn't it
because I think that's that that that's
getting everything in the muddle and
there's the wrong reason for doing
anything
um I I hope the feeling is that that
they're trusting bows there because of
his great performance last year when he
he made all those runs and that they
feel that he must come good I don't know
what view they take on is where he
keeping that's what worries me I'm sure
you see again if you look at pasto's
test record uh when he doesn't keep
Wicked when he doesn't have the gloves
he averages very much more than when
he's keeping Wicked I ain't understand
this if you're going to stand behind the
stumps um for uh six seven eight hours
and then going about an awful lot is
being put on your shoulders and and and
you know I I see this and I think again
it's another reason why I would have
picked folks
uh Jeffrey boycott who is someone who
you don't always see eye to eye with uh
he has suggested uh dropping birthstone
but and also um getting Maureen Elliott
out the picture uh would you agree with
that the second one a matter of Interest
I I haven't seen what everybody got has
said who would he pick as a spinner or
would he not big I'm not sure he even
mentioned that actually uh because I
thought Moon Alley actually
um played a part and he played a part it
positively in getting out of lavish air
and Smith on that evening and he then
played a sort of negative positive part
if you see what I mean by opting and
going up the Stoke and saying I want
about three in the second Innings he'd
only got five fair enough but he enabled
Harry Brook to go back to the to number
five which is his favorite position and
and we saw how well that worked he made
75 and he won the match really so I
think we
in terms of figures again may not be um
may not be brilliant and may not be a
natural choice but I very much admire
the spirits of the man and I think in a
tight contest which is going to be I
think I'd like to have him in my side
and presumably you would also like to
have uh Mark Wood in your side because
he was man of the match oh yeah terrific
my goodness me and Mark Wood and wokes
do weren't they terrific I mean would we
see now what if you vote at 95 miles an
hour my goodness it looks different
getting the fish doesn't it yeah I mean
those holidays didn't like that and I I
thought he was Amsterdam magnificent and
he's passing too the way he came in and
I I always say he took a chance and got
away that he hit that six in the closing
stages which really sealed England's
victory I dealt with magnificent and
when you hear him talking he's a chat
with confidence and he you know when the
Australians see him they know they've
got a fight on their hands I'm Overwood
and I'm all for wokes too I thought he'd
added magnificently in that uh well in
both innings in fact but particularly in
the segment Andy took six wickets and
when you have to compare him to Jimmy
Anderson really I suppose he replaced in
a sense well I didn't know did wood
replace him but anyway okay uh wokes did
a wonderful job and I think probably
um although it's sad in a nostalgic way
I don't think I would play I mean I know
I wouldn't play Jimmy Anderson at Old
rapid because I think I'm afraid the
time has come he's past 40. it's a very
tough series and and this is going to be
a very tough match I know he's a
wonderful Craig he's probably England's
best ever bowler but I think the time
has come and you've got now uh to go to
the the Woodworks and that lot
uh you said last time I think that uh
you thought the the weather might stop
uh England coming back and winning this
series 3-2 well I I I only said on the
law of averages it's very remarkable if
you'll get through an England summer
without the rain having a decisive
effect on on on on one of the five test
matches either in terms of washing it
out altogether or making it impossible
to get a result or indeed giving one
side a a a strong Advantage but actually
with covered pictures of course that is
less likely to happen is this yes
um and lastly Henry if you don't mind uh
we we had a little bit of pushback I
believe to your uh diary and your
appearance here last week where you
talked about this report into English
Cricket uh and you suggested uh uh that
it was it was had an agenda and that the
agenda or it may have had an agenda uh
and may have been motivated by a sort of
hostility towards English cricket and
and perhaps sort of English no what I
would what I what I was saying really
was that this was
was terribly important and I think but
when uh a group of people was appointed
to look into English Cricket it was
terribly important that they were seen
to be utterly fair and as it happens
um I've got nothing against Cindy bets
at all I were headed the the
commissioner whatever you call it and
nothing is of course I have made it I've
never met her but she is an activist a
black lives matter and I think a one or
two or three of her colleagues in this
and it makes you think that they may
have come from with a with an agenda
with an ax to grind that may be
unparable but nonetheless I think it's
worth pointing out and I do think that
that in this situation one needed to
pick a group that were able to look at
it in an absolutely even-handed way
because I still don't believe I've
talked to all other people involved in
cricket and they don't recognize or that
or they don't think this report
represents the game they played and I I
mean I I'm okay there may be a lot of
things wrong with English Greek but I
don't think that it's quite as bad as it
was made out to be in this report it if
I'm wrong I will hold my hand up and say
I'm sorry but I I've got nothing
personal against any of the people
involved it just is I think we've got a
sort of Affair about this and really get
to the bottom of it before we start
introducing Draconian measures and
there's no point in including Draconian
measures if
what they are meant to cure is not quite
as bad as we think I don't know we
there's an awful lot to be done in this
I think I think
it's interesting is it not that uh I
think you've been pretty fair-minded
there and you're not actually making uh
aggressive claims but that you that just
merely by floating the idea that the
report
um may not have been entirely Fair uh
you're getting quite a lot of a flack
oh that's inevitable isn't it I mean of
course the messenger gets it uh I mean
indeed I I but I think at my vast days I
can probably withstand that I'm not
being in any way Eastern in this all the
way
um you know at all but I just would say
I think it should I want it to be seen
that this is is a fair
um criticism of all that's going on and
it seems to me extraordinary if it's as
bad as was suggested that no one no one
has drawn has shown a light on it before
now
well uh Henry we will end it there but
thank you very very much indeed for
coming on spectator TV again and uh I
hope we'll get you again after all
Trafford and the series will be nicely
squared at two all
well it wouldn't it be lovely wouldn't
it be lovely and I look forward to that
thank you
[Music]